[Musik]
und jetzt das heute journal
der letzte flieger der us-streitkräfte
hebt in kabul ab mit an bord der general
der die 82 luftlande division
kommandierte mit ihm hat nun auch der
letzte amerikanische soldat afghanistan
verlassen
guten abend zum heute journal als das
flugzeug am horizont verschwand waren in
kabul die freudenschüsse der taliban zu
hören mit ihnen wird nun umzugehen sein
der deutsche außenminister ist heute
abend schon in katar das ehrgeizige
kleinere wüsten-emirat richtet
neuerdings nicht nur fußball
weltmeisterschaften aus sondern tritt
auch als großer player auf der
diplomatischen weltbühne auf in katars
hauptstadt doha haben die taliban schon
seit längerem ihre diplomatische
außenstelle eingerichtet
mit diesem duo hat tipps wie sie im
diplomaten jargon auch genannt werden
ist ja auch deutschland bereits im
gespräch dazu gleich noch ein interview
mit heiko maas doch zunächst schauen wir
in die usa wie geht amerika mit dem
bitteren ende dieses 20-jährigen
einsatzes im atelier sind berichtet
der alptraum für die supermacht taliban
kämpfer in der montur von amerikanischen
elite soldaten freuen sich über
us-hubschrauber ein reporter der los
angeles times dokumentiert den moment
der niederlage auch wenn die maschinen
flugunfähig sind
zum selbstbild der supermacht gehört
dass sie eigentlich keine niederlage
erleidet deshalb wollten beiden kritiker
dass er sie irgendwie als siegt aussehen
lässt oder wenigstens als unentschieden
vergeblich
für die amerikaner die noch da sind gibt
es keine denn wir sind entschlossen sie
raus zu bekommen wenn sie wolle
außenminister blinken führt die
diplomatischen bemühungen um eine
sichere ausreise für alle amerikaner
aller afghanischen partner und ausländer
die afghanistan verlassen wollen
am versagen amerikas lassen die taliban
keinen zweifel feuerwerk freudenschüsse
autokorso kurz nachdem der letzte
us-soldat der kommandierende general
dorner you in den flieger klettern die
supermacht 20 jahre krieg hinter sich
lässt mit ähnlichen bildern hatte es
begonnen oktober 2001 us ranger springen
ab im konflikt am hindukusch würden
dreieinhalbtausend alliierte soldaten
sterben zehntausende verletzt werden der
maßstab für erfolg war für die usa nie
in erster linie die errichtung einer
dauerhaften demokratie in afghanistan
sondern der fortschritt im kampf gegen
den terror
fangen wir töten wir schrecken wir mehr
terroristen haben als die radikalen
islamisten rekrutieren
finanzieren trainieren ausrüsten und an
stiften können um da draußen unschuldige
männer frauen und kinder zu töten
die technologie des tötens wurde besser
die lage in afghanistan nicht wirklich
auch nicht als präsident obama im mai
2001 amerikas wichtigsten sieg errang
die tötung osama bin ladens
die us truppen und ihre verbündeten
blieben verhasste im ländlichen
afghanistan afghanische soldaten wurden
teuer ausgebildet und ausgerüstet aber
ihren sold bekamen sie oft nicht und
wenig rückendeckung von ihren anführern
von hamid karsai bis zu afghanistan
in den vierteljährlichen berichten des
us generalinspekteur für
afghanistan
wir haben massen von geld versenkt die
kultur und gesellschaft mit dollar
korrumpiert jetzt sind wir überrascht 20
jahre später über kriegsfürsten und die
reichen fetten korrupten anführer
auch deshalb war das hier nicht wirklich
zu verhindern ohne wieder richtig krieg
zu führen die usa die nato auch
deutschland gescheitert sie hatten viel
zu viel versprochen und müssen jetzt mit
den taliban verhandeln damit die
menschen die jetzt zur grenze flüchten
nicht ihre letzte hoffnung auch noch
verlieren
und der bundesaußenminister ist uns
zugeschaltete es haben ende seiner reise
jetzt in doha in katar guten abend herr
maas
hallo guten onkel in doha finden auch
gespräche wenn auch nicht von ihnen
persönlich mit den taliban statt was
hören sie wie so verlaufen
wir hören einiges dabei durchaus auch
positive dinge etwa dass die taliban
sich bereit erklärt haben dass afghanen
und abgaben auch nach dem 31 august
legal aus afghanistan ausreisen können
aber letztlich sind das erst mal nur
worte es wird darum gehen dass das jetzt
auch taten werden darüber sprechen wir
mit den kollegen aus katar die in sehr
engen draht zu den taliban haben darüber
sprechen wir aber auch selber mit den
taliban und das wird jetzt auch die
kommenden tage und wochen ankommen ob
man auf das wort es da gegeben wurde ob
man auf dieses wort sich auch verlassen
können nun werden die ja nicht
irgendetwas aus menschenfreundlichkeit
tun sondern sie wollen dazu im gegenzug
etwas haben was kann man überhaupt
bieten
es gibt einige dinge die dir haben
wollen sie wollen zum beispiel dass der
flughafen weiter betrieben wird das ist
einer der gründe warum ich hier in katar
bilden und auch am sonntag in der türkei
gewesen bin diese beiden länder zusammen
mit den amerikanern haben sich bereit
erklärt auch nach dem ende der
militärischen evakuierung den flughafen
weiter zu betreiben zumindest in einer
ersten phase in der es möglich wäre
einige charterflüge keine militärflüge
mehr durchzuführen mit dem dann auch
weiter menschen evakuiert werden können
das ist etwas woran die taliban ein
interesse haben weil sie brauchen auch
einen flughafen der funktioniert und
wenn länder sich dafür zur verfügung
stellen dann ist es glaube ich
vollkommen klar dass wir auch unsere
erwartungen haben und eine dieser
erwartung ist dass wir weiter unsere
staatsbürger und auch unsere ortskräfte
ausfliegen können wenn der flughafen
wieder geöffnet wird im moment geht es
ja erst mal darum das ist auch der
hauptgrund ihrer reise herauszufinden
wie man aufgaben und auch deutsche
staatsbürger aus dem landweg über den
landweg herausbekommen kann zum beispiel
bei usbekistan haben sie da eine
konkrete zusage dass das dann auch
funktionieren wird die leute müssen ja
aus kabul oder masar i scharif da erst
mal hinkommen schon zum flughafen war es
ja so verdammt gefährlich durchs land zu
reisen durch die taliban check points
ist ja noch gefährlicher
aber auch darüber sprechen wir mit den
taliban aber vor allen dingen sprechen
wir mit denen ländern die eine grenze zu
afghanistan haben wie usbekistan
tadschikistan und auch pakistan die
bereitschaft dort afghanische
flüchtlinge aufzunehmen ist nicht sehr
ausgeprägt um es mal so zu sagen aber
die bereitschaft deutscher staatsbürger
über ihre länder ausreisen zu lassen und
auch ortskräfte bei denen wir die
bereitschaft erklärt haben sie
unmittelbar weiter nach deutschland
auszufliegen die gibt es darüber haben
wir gesprochen wie das funktionieren
kann dafür brauchen wir einen
mechanismus und zum glück hat es heute
ja schon mal funktioniert war eine
gruppe von etwa 100 ortskräfte über den
landweg nach pakistan gereist sind die
wurden dort weil wir mit den behörden
entsprechend des vorbereitet haben auch
ins land gelassen die können jetzt der
deutschen botschaft bekommt sie bekommen
ihre papiere und die können dann
islamabad nach deutschland ausfliegen
also es gibt weiter möglichkeiten
wir brauchen aber mechanismen damit das
auch in zukunft weiter funktioniert
sowohl mit den nachbarstaaten aber auch
mit den taliban in afghanistan
wenn man ehrlich ist hat sich der westen
im prinzip jetzt gegenüber den taliban
erpressbar gemacht die werden alles
mögliche fordern geld entwicklungshilfe
völkerrechtliche anerkennung und auch
dann kann man sich nicht darauf
verlassen dass jeder toilette an
irgendeinem checkpoint steht weiß dass
das jetzt ein konvoi mit deutschen ist
das ist so aber das könne nicht dazu
führen dass wir uns jetzt nicht weiter
bemühen die taliban kann auffordern was
sie wollen wir haben auch klare
voraussetzungen definiert das sind die
einhaltung der menschenrechte das ist
die tatsache dass überhaupt menschen
weiter ausreisen können das ist es
keinen terroristischen gruppen
unterschlupf gegeben wird in afghanistan
aber natürlich haben haben die taliban
auch interessen sie werden dieses land
nicht alleine regieren können ohne dass
sie auf internationale hilfe angewiesen
sind und die internationale hilfe und da
gibt es große einigkeit auf der
internationalen bühne die kann es nur
geben wenn auch gewisse benchmarks die
für uns alle gelten die im übrigen die
gleichen sind die auch für die bisherige
afghanische regierung gegolten haben
wenn die eingehalten werden wie viele
deutsche staatsbürger sind in einklang
mit noch in afghanistan die rausgeholt
werden müssen
wir gehen davon aus dass etwa 300
deutschen staatsbürgers kommen aber
immer noch welche hinzu die sich noch
melden in afghanistan sind wir stehen
mit diesen in kontakt und das sind
diejenigen für die wir uns natürlich
ganz besonders bemühen
ausreisemöglichkeiten jetzt im moment
über land zu schaffen außerdem gibt es
diese zahl 40.000 damit sind auch
ortskräfte vor allen dingen gemeint die
mit deutsche institutionen
zusammengearbeitet haben das ist nun
doch plötzlich sehr viel mehr als die
2500 von denen anfangs immer die rede
war
naja das hat auch dazu geführt dass sich
in den letzten wochen in den letzten
tagen immer mehr dieser ortskräfte
gemeldet haben die sich registriert
haben und die eine gefährdung sun zeige
gestellt haben dass sie sich also
gefährdet fühlen das ist der effekt
gewesen der eingetreten ist nachdem die
taliban in kabul die macht übernommen
haben die zahlen die wir jetzt haben
bieten aber einen guten überblick über
diejenigen die in vielen jahren
beschäftigt gewesen sind entwickler
entweder bei uns bei deutschen behörden
oder auch bei angeles oder sonstigen
institutionen etwa in der
entwicklungshilfe und diese zahl ist in
den letzten tagen immer weiter gestiegen
herr maas danken für das gespräch
das interview hervor anderthalb stunden
aufgezeichnet sich die taliban an
benchmarks halten werden im moment sieht
es eher so aus als wollten die taliban
das rad der zeit möglichst schnell
zurück drehen was übrigens auch zeigt
dass in diesen 20 jahren westliche
intervention durchaus etwas erreicht
wurde vor allem in den städten mädchen
ging zur schule frauen verdienten geld
machten hochschulabschlüsse hatten
wahlrecht besetzten politische ämter was
wird nun aus ging was wir dazu aus
afghanistan hören ist niederschmetternd
herein berichtet
[Musik]
ich lebe alleine mit meinen vier kindern
mein mann ist gestorben seit die taliban
hier sind traue ich mich kaum noch auf
die straße auch zu hause habe ich angst
das leben ist ohnehin schon schwer genug
für mich was aus uns wird das weiß ich
nicht
[Musik]
diese bilder von ihrem heimatort in der
provinz parwan hat ein bekannter der
frau gedreht nach dem schock den die
machtübernahme der taliban ausgelöst hat
geht das leben langsam weiter auf dem
basar wird gehandelt und frauen sind
zwar zu sehen doch ihre freiheit ist
durch die islamisten besonders bedroht
es geht nicht nur darum ob wir auf die
straße gehen dürfen die frage ist werden
wir ein wahlrecht haben werden wir
gleichberechtigt mit männern sein werden
wir vollwertige mitglieder dieser
gesellschaft sein wird eine frau ihr
eigenes geld verdienen und besitzen
dürfen wird sie eigenständig ohne einen
man leben können
die junge frau hat das video aus der
hauptstadt kabul geschickt das haus
verlasse sie im moment nicht dabei hatte
sie bis vor kurzem einen guten job ihr
foto sei von der website ihres
arbeitgebers bereits verschwunden von
unterdrückung durch die taliban
berichtet auch diese lehrerin aus masar
i scharif
sie sagen uns dass wir in die schule
kommen und unterrichten sollen wenn wir
bereit sein auf unser gehalt zu
verzichten gut wenn nicht sollten wir
gefälligst zu hause bleiben auf der
straße peitschen sie menschen aus einen
jungen haben sie vor meinen augen blutig
geschlagen
szenen die an die taliban herrschaft in
den 90er jahren erinnern
schmerzhaft ist das auch für die
menschen die ihr land aufbauen wollten
so wie die junge frau aus kabul sie
gehört zur gut ausgebildeten elite des
landes und muss jetzt zuschauen wie
islamisten das bisher geleistete
zunichte machen
was wird aus dem was wir frauen bisher
erreicht haben werden wir unsere
fähigkeiten einsetzen können um die
gesellschaft voranzubringen was wird aus
unseren mädchen werden sie eine gute
ausbildung bekommen
wir wissen nicht was aus uns und unserem
leben wird
dass die frauen uns ihre botschaften
geschickt haben ist extrem mutig und zur
zeit keine selbstverständlichkeit sie
wollten es dennoch tun für all jene die
nicht die möglichkeit haben gehört zu
werden
wir werden ihn weiter gehör verschaffen
gehen jetzt aber zurück nach deutschland
und zum deutschen wahlkampf beim
kandidaten tree l ließ sich zuletzt ja
auch ganz gut beobachten mit welcher
rollenverteilung die drei in die
schlacht ziehen während frau werburg als
angreiferin aus der opposition auftritt
erwecken armin laschet olaf scholz den
eindruck eigentlich so eine art
fortsetzung von frau merkel zu sein nur
besser laschet will moderner scholz
sozialer sein
olaf scholz scheint von seiner
vizekanzler schafft tatsächlich zu
profitieren die formulierung die
kanzlerin und ich komm team entsprechend
locker über die lippen und letztens wies
er sich für das magazin der süddeutschen
zeitung ja sogar mit der merkel raute
fotografieren bei der union empfand man
das geradezu als provokation markus
söder schimpfte sogar scholz betreibe ab
schleiferei und jetzt wird es wohl auch
der kanzlerin selbst etwas zu bunt sie
schickte heute jedenfalls einer ziemlich
giftige botschaft an den spd kandidaten
mit mir als bundeskanzlerin wurde es nie
eine koalition geben in der die linke
beteiligt ist und ob dies von olaf
scholz zugeteilt wird oder nicht das
bleibt offen und in dem zusammenhang ist
es einfach so dass da ein gewaltiger
unterschied für die zukunft deutschlands
zwischen mir und ihm besteht
theo koll in berlin damit hat sich die
kanzlerin jahr überraschend deutlich in
den wahlkampf angeklickt ja das kann man
sagen und es fällt wohl aus zwei gründen
besonders stark auf erstens weil sich
die kanzlerin ja bisher weitestgehend
aus dem wahlkampf herausgehalten hat bis
auf einen eher mageren auftritt zum
auftakt und zweitens weil sie heute voll
auf die achillesferse von olaf scholz
gezielt hat auf ein mögliches rot grün
rotes bündnis ist laut umfrage ihr
rechnerisch möglich und olaf scholz ist
an einen spd parteitagsbeschluss von
2013 gebunden der vorsieht auf bündnisse
mit der linkspartei nicht grundsätzlich
auszuschließen und scholz will sich
natürlich für mögliche
koalitionsverhandlungen mit der fdp eine
art poker karte linksbündnis sich ja
nach dem motto ich könnte auch anders
für die union jedenfalls war die heute
mit einer roten socke winken die
kanzlerin ein unverhofftes und lang
ersehntes wahlgeschenk aber man merkt
aber natürlich auch unter welchen druck
der union jetzt in diesen letzten
wahlkampfwochen steht absolut also in
der union wird jetzt bei jeder
gelegenheit betont dass es sehr knapp
wird und es um jede stimme geht und dazu
passt natürlich auch dass laschet heute
friedrich merz quasi eine ministerielle
jobgarantie gegeben hat wäre zitat das
wirtschafts- und finanzpolitische
gesicht der union werden und in der
regierung eine wichtige position
einnehmen das kann eigentlich nur heißen
dass peter altmaier schon mal seine
sachen sortieren sollte weil in einem
möglichen kabinett laschet an merz
wirtschaftsminister werden würde denn um
das finanzministerium streiten sich ja
jetzt schon grüne und fdp aber auch das
ist natürlich alles wahlkampf geklingelt
und das sei hier deutlich an den beeren
und an seinen viel erinnert dankeschön
jetzt geht's mit nachrichten und hans
wolff weiter und da auch zunächst noch
mal mit denen afghanistan thema die eu
will zunächst keine konkreten zusagen
zur aufnahme von flüchtlingen aus
afghanistan machen anreize zur illegalen
migration sollten vermieden werden heißt
es in einer erklärung die bei einem
sondertreffen der innenminister in
brüssel verabschiedet wurde
zugleich wolle die eu vor ort helfen
damit notleidende menschen in der
unmittelbaren nachbarschaft afghanistans
angemessenen schutz erhalten im
september will die eu ein hochrangiges
forum zur frage besonders
schutzbedürftiger organisieren
und zur haltung der eu in der
flüchtlingsfrage haben wir in unserem
heutigen hat update auch ein gespräch
mit dem luxemburgischen außen und
migrationsminister asselborn
angela merkel ist mit der buber
rosenzweig medaille geehrt worden damit
würdigte der deutsche koordinierungsrat
der gesellschaften für christlich
jüdische zusammenarbeit merkels
engagement gegen rassistische und
antisemitische tendenzen
die bundeskanzlerin habe sich für israel
und das miteinander der religionen
eingesetzt so josef schuster präsident
des zentralrats der juden merkel nannte
es eine bleibende aufgabe jüdisches
leben in deutschland zu stärken und zu
schützen
die zahl der arbeitslosen in deutschland
ist im august zurückgegangen der
arbeitsmarkt habe sich weiter erholt
sagte der chef der bundesagentur für
arbeit schiene laut bundesagentur waren
im august zwei millionen
578.000 menschen ohne job das sind
12.000 weniger als im juli die
arbeitslosenquote liegt bei 5,6 prozent
im vergleich zum vorjahr waren
377.000 menschen weniger ohne arbeit
70 prozent der erwachsenen bevölkerung
in der eu sind mittlerweile vollständig
gegen das corona virus geimpft das gab
die eu kommission heute bekannt damit
hat die eu ihr selbst gestecktes ziel
erreicht zu den infektionszahlen in
deutschland das rk ii meldet
5750 neue corona fälle innerhalb von 24
stunden drei mehr als am vergangenen
dienstag 60 todesfälle kamen hinzu
erstmals seit wochen sinkt die sieben
tage incident sie liegt nun bei
74,8
mit blick auf die korona kennzahlen will
die bundesregierung künftig stärker auf
die krankenhauseinweisungen schauen und
weniger auf die reine instituts eine
entsprechende vorlage hat das
bundeskabinett heute beschlossen um das
infektionsschutzgesetz zu ändern danach
soll die sogenannte
hospitalisierung rate ein zentraler wert
werden was es damit auf sich hat
erläutert sibylle bassler und ralph
koschek
die hospitalisierung incidents sie gilt
als der neue wirt der die situation in
den krankenhäusern und damit das
pandemie geschehen neu bewerten soll
wenn die anzahl derer die ins
krankenhaus müssen das heißt die
hospitalisierung incidents hoch ist dann
heißt es wir haben eine hohe menge an
infektionen das heißt es ein sehr
exakter parameter den ich tagesgenau und
auch regional aufgelöst bestimmen kann
erstmals seit mitte juni sind bundesweit
wieder mehr als 1000 kubik patienten auf
intensivstationen
so die vereinigung von intensiv und
notfallmedizin
das alarmiert einzelne bundesländer wie
auch bayern die sieben tage ins ident
sie reichen nicht mehr um der aktuellen
situation gerecht zu werden es gilt das
gesundheitssystem zu schützen die
sicherheitsschranke ist allein die
belegung der krankenhäuser wir nennen es
die krankenhaus ampeln danach etablieren
wir zwei warnstufe gelb und rot für
bayern bedeutet dies konkret werden mehr
als 1200 patienten wegen cupid innerhalb
der letzten sieben tage im krankenhaus
aufgenommen gilt warnstufe gilt
bei mehr als 600 patienten auf den
intensivstationen
herrscht alarmstufe rot für das berliner
gesundheitssystem wurde die bestehende
ampel ebenso modifiziert auch hier kommt
ab september der neue parameter hinzu so
die berliner gesundheitssenatorin heute
sieben tages hospitalisierung since it
ends das heißt wir schauen wie viele was
vitalisierung fälle gab es in den
letzten sieben tagen das bezogen auf die
100.000
berlinerinnen und berliner tatsache ist
dass jedes bundesland unterschiedliche
hospitalisierung warnstufen installieren
kann nur um welche maßnahmen es sich
dabei handelt ist offen und wie schnell
sie greifen ebenso auch die gefahr eines
flickenteppichs sieht der vorstand der
stiftung patientenschutz
es ist von bedeutung zu wissen wann
werden welche maßnahmen tatsächlich
eingeleitet ist das bei einer
hospitalisierung rate von 5 von 10 oder
von 15 und es kann nicht sein dass jedes
bundesland eine andere lösung macht der
mainzer mediziner professor christian
werner sieht darin allerdings kein
problem
das ist ganz bestimmte richtige schritte
in einer situation wo letztendlich ja
das schiere erkrankungs geschehen
entscheidet es dafür wie im
gesundheitswesen zu steuer wäre und
dennoch befürchten einige wenn die zahl
der kubik patienten auf den
intensivstationen
bundesweit steigt könnte es schwierig
werden schnell da gegenzusteuern
und dann schnell noch eine korrektur im
bericht vor hinaus washington ließ osama
bin laden seit 2001 getötet worden das
war aber natürlich 2011 und jetzt
nochmal eins mit dem blick auf die
wirtschaft corona krise lieferengpässe
bei computerchips wie läuft es in diesem
umfeld für die weltweite autoindustrie
zu den ersten sechs monaten dieses
jahres gibt es neue zahlen valerie
haller wie sieht es demnach aus besser
als erwartet ganz überraschend laut
einer neuen studie hat die auto branche
die korona krise nämlich ziemlich
schnell hinter sich gelassen ja und das
wirklich erstaunliche autokonzerne
verkauften zwar weniger autos als vor
corinna aber sie sind profitabler das
haben sie dem trend zu verdanken dass
teure modelle gerade besonders gefragt
ja und die werfen einfach mehr gewinn ab
als günstigere autos hinzu kommt dass
die branche die korona krise dazu
genutzt hat sparprogramme aufzulegen und
die zahlen sich jetzt aus ein phänomenal
starkes erstes halbjahr für die 16
größten autokonzerne der welt rund 71
milliarden euro gewinn und das nach
einem verlust von rund 4 milliarden im
gleichen zeitraum vor einem jahr
allerdings schlug da die korona krise
voll ins kontor besonders erfolgreich in
der ersten jahreshälfte deutsche
autokonzerne darunter vor allem bmw und
daimler sie arbeiteten weltweit am
profitabelsten autobauer auch an der
börse hoch im kurs volkswagen daimler
bmw alle seit jahresbeginn zweistellig
im plus lieferengpässe und chip mangel
haben die auto branche im vergangenen
jahr in die krise gestürzt jetzt ist der
chip mangel sogar ein vorteil die
nachfrage nach autos ist groß das
angebot gering die autokonzerne wissen
dass für sich zu nutzen und geben
weniger rabatte valerie haller vielen
dank
nach dem hurrikan ida über regionen im
süden der usa gezogen ist hat sich die
zahl der todesopfer auf vier erhöht die
behörden haben immer noch keine genauen
überblick über die schäden der grund
viele gebiete wurden abgeschnitten weil
das telefon- und handynetz nicht
funktioniert denn wichtige versorgung
straßen wurden unterbrochen
hunderttausende menschen werden wohl
mehrere wochen ohne strom sein die
nationalgarde ist mit 5000 soldaten im
einsatz
und im us bundesstaat kalifornien
kämpfen tausende feuerwehrleute immer
noch gegen die schweren waldbrände eine
fläche von 700 quadratkilometern wurde
bereits vom sogenannten kardorf feuer
zerstört hunderte häuser brannten nieder
22.000 menschen wurden rund um den lake
tahoe aufgefordert die beliebte
touristenregion zu verlassen auf den
umliegenden straßen kam es zu
kilometerlangen staus auch die
nachbargemeinden sind aufgefordert sich
auf eine anstehende evakuierung
vorzubereiten
das war es von uns beiden an diesem
dienstagabend nachher im heute schon
update bringt sie dann christopher
wehrmann auf den neuesten nachrichten
stand
[Musik]
ein schwimm brüder ante und herzlich
willkommen zum wetter die tiefs über
mitteleuropa verabschieden sich
allmählich das hoch über den britischen
inseln dehnt sich weiter aus ist es ein
sehr umfangreiches hoch ein sehr starkes
lenkt kühle luft richtung osteuropa aber
bei uns wird es allmählich wärmer mit
dem wohn luftdruck das sehen wir auch
auf der karte für europa für morgen bei
uns klettern die temperaturen leicht
über die 20 grad marke während es im
osten durchaus etwas kühler ist in der
nacht lässt der regen ganz im süden
deutschlands nach sonst funkeln vor
allem entlang der küsten die sterne im
nordwesten da bildet sich nebel mit
tiefsten temperaturen an den küsten um
14 grad 6 bis 7 am kühlsten ist es ganz
im süden deutschlands morgen
tagesverlauf wieder viel sonne ganz im
norden also von der ostsee bis richtung
schleswig holstein und auch vom
alpenrand richtung oberrhein scheint die
meiste zeit die sonne in der mitte
deutschlands auch mal kompakte wolken
aber auch dort zeigt sich dann mal die
sonne temperaturen höchste werte von 17
grad in den westlichen mittelgebirgen
24 grad im südwesten deutschlands dort
wird es morgen am wärmsten also fast ein
sommertag die kommenden tage es wird
sonniger und vor allem auch wärmer
donnerstag vor allem im osten sehr viel
sonnenschein im süden durchaus auch zu
tagesbeginn mit nebel 25 grad und die
darauf folgenden tage haben wir sogar 26
grad damit ein schöner abend